i guess the first thing to say is
they're a consequence of general
relativity that when you get as far as
writing down the equations for general
relativity and start trying to solve
them you find that some of the solutions
involve these wave solutions they're
distortions of the space time that
proper get out i mean they're important
for lots of reasons they're important
because they are a prediction of general
relativity so actually if you then
detect them you found further
confirmation that general relativity is
actually right whenever mata passes by
through some region of space time it
will distort the space time just like
you would distort water when you put
your fingers through water and waves
propagate out this is a propagation of
the space time itself so the space time
is
is sort of moving in and out propagating
out at the speed of light but also
because in principle at least they open
up an entire new window on the universe
everything almost everything we've done
in astronomy barring a few cosmic rays
and neutrinos has been mediated through
light we've used light to figure out
what's going on in the universe having
an entirely new way of detecting what's
going on out there in the universe is a
very exciting thing for astronomers
because it opens up all sorts of new
avenues for us to pursue in research as
the earth goes around the sun
then the space time is distorting around
the earth and that's and that's
propagating out in waves in all
directions but those waves have nothing
to do with for example why the moon is
attracted to no
no they're different gravity that that's
a different aspect sometimes we call
them gravitational waves but they're
they're different here these are the the
tides don't
um exist because of the nature of
gravitational waves uh propagating
you've got the earth going around the
sun and then you've got the moon going
around the earth these are very massive
objects right and so there's a net
attraction just due to the pure mass of
these objects and that's where the tides
come from the large mass of the moon and
the even larger mass of the earth and as
they go around the water that's on the
earth gets distorted by the changing
gravitational field due to the
huge mass of the moon and the earth
but on top of that there's like a
secondary effect going as as the moon is
going around it's causing ripples
in the space-time and it's those ripple
these are minuscule ripples that are
propagating out and it's those that
recently were detected not from the moon
but from
two massive supermassive well not
supermassive two massive black holes
that were orbiting each other and so
they distorted the space time enough
that these waves that propagated out
they could be detected here on earth i
said space is expanding and contracting
but the amount that space is expanding
and contracting by is absolutely
minuscule so this
big result that came up with this thing
that they detected the amount by which
space was expanding over the many
kilometers of their detector was less
than the diameter of the nucleus of an
atom so it's an absolutely tiny effect
that's why we don't sort of notice them
going past because if there were big
effects you know you'd see kind of space
doing all sorts of weird things but
because they're so tiny we just don't
see them it's just amazing i mean the
numbers involved the timing involved
it's a spectacular event so
a billion light years away
450 megaparsecs away
so billion years ago
two black holes
which were each of them
30 times the mass of the sun okay which
is unusual apparently in its own right
to get this kind of combination
they were orbiting they'd been orbiting
each other
for probably millions of years anyway
well they have to be bound together
because they were in orbit around one
another and it's actually quite
complicated because so the way you get
massive black holes is you have some
very massive star exploding in a
supernova
and unless that supernova is set up very
carefully if you imagine you had a pair
of binary star binary star in orbit
around one another one of them goes
supernova if you're not very careful
that's going to unbind the system
because you've lost the whole load of
mass there's all sorts of energy being
transferred between one and the other so
somehow the two managed to stay bound
together it would seem when first one
went supernova and then a bit later the
other one went supernova i said a bit
you know probably tens to hundreds of
thousands of years later the other one
went supernova alternatively possibly if
both of these stars were in a cluster
they might actually have individually
been separate stars and at some point in
the subsequent evolution they might have
actually got sufficiently close together
that they end up capturing each other
and end up in a binary system that way
so it is a little bit of a mystery how
you make these two massive black holes
fairly massive not super massive black
holes in orbit around one another in the
first place but they're at least kind of
plausible mechanisms for doing it so
they're doing this for millions and
millions of years
and then in the final
i think it's 0.2 of a second as they're
coming closer and closer together
they start going so rapidly around one
another they begin to approach the speed
of light in fact something like sixty
percent of the speed of light
these are thirty solar mass black holes
as they come in closer and closer
when they're about i think 350
kilometers apart they basically start
merging together amazingly from just
looking at the kind of signal they
detect they can learn a great deal about
the kind of black holes it actually was
how the amplitude changes with time how
the frequency of the signal changes with
time so in this case they're fairly
confident that one of them was a 29
solar mass black hole and the other one
was a 36 solar mass black hole they've
got sort of errors of one or two solar
masses on each one but there are both 30
to 40 solar mass black holes so those
are the kind of black holes which are
probably the end states of very massive
stars although they are actually on the
high side even for very massive stars
remember we've talked about this
intricate link between the matter and
the space time just imagine
trying to imagine these two huge objects
what they're doing to the matter to the
space time around it as they and the
space time must be going oh my god
what's happening here and it's flipping
up and down up and down and they're just
generating
these waves are beginning to propagate
out 350 kilometers about the distance
what to london
then you've got two 30 solar mass black
holes sort of orbiting one another in
this region and so they're going and at
close to the speed of light so the the
the space time in which it's evolving it
must be going
having huge distortions associated with
it and so it begins to send out
gravitational waves they've been
happening all the time but at a much
lower amplitude because they've not been
feeling this effect like this
and then the the these two black holes
keep coming in together and they merge
and what happens is when you've got two
black holes they'll merge into a bigger
black hole so one of them is 29 solar
masses the other one is 36 solar masses
if you add those two together you get 65
solar masses so you would think by
merging these two together you make a 65
solar mass black hole turns out they can
also tell you what the mass of the black
hole they ended up with was again just
by looking at the kind of signal and
it's not 65 solar masses it's about 62
solar masses
and the reason why is because three
solar masses has disappeared
and via einstein's famous formula e
equals m c squared those three solar
masses of energy
have all been turned into the energy of
the gravitational waves so three solar
masses via e equals mc squared has been
turned into
a huge amount of energy liberated in
this gravitational wave explosion in
fact if you work out what the luminosity
of the thing was how bright it was in
gravitational waves in that fraction of
a second as all this happened
it was brighter it was liberating more
energy more power than all the stars in
the entire observable universe for that
fraction of a second all in
gravitational waves
but there was no light well there might
be
there may well have been some light as
well but that was just what was coming
out in gravitational waves mostly the
energy of this merger was coming out in
these sunbursts of gravitational waves
they're traveling now if they've got a
billion years they're traveling all
directions they propagate and then as it
happens there's a detector two detectors
in america had been recently updated and
they've just been turned on they were
doing i think they call it the
engineering run they haven't even
started doing the proper science run
they've been turned on for a few weeks
and a few billion years later these
waves are coming through now they've
lost a lot of their energy right as just
as light loses its energy and
and becomes dimmer and dimmer the the
huge
amplitude associated with the waves
early on is now dimmed down down down
down they pass through this detector and
the detector consists of two arms four
kilometer long arms an interferometer
classic interferometer has two arms to
it and you basically shine a light down
each arm usually a laser because you
want it to be nice coherent light
and in essence you shine the light
backwards and forwards along each of
these arms by recombining the light you
can essentially tune the thing so that
the two arms are exactly the same length
as each other
okay and and if you set up your
interferometer right then the light
that's gone down this arm and the light
that goes down this arm exactly
cancelled each other out so you end up
with no signal at all
okay and so that's a thing called a
nulling interferometer it's set to you
get zero signal when the two arms are
actually tuned in that way now of course
when one of these waves goes past
in one direction it actually causes a
contraction and in the other direction
actually causes an expansion
this back and forth stretching and
squeezing happens over and over until
the wave has passed as the wave goes
past by this tiny tiny amount the arms
will no longer be exactly the same
length and the effect of that is then
that exact cancellation ceases to work
and suddenly some of the light gets
through your interferometer so the way
they actually detect it is that they
actually start seeing light in their
interferometer because the arms have
changed in length by that tiny amount
this huge amount of energy
required
this
desperately accurate
detector in order to be able to find the
gravitational waves
and then you might ask how do you know
you've found the gravitational wave
surely everything distorts it seems like
an instrument that
a mosquito sneezing would affect them
and they get huge numbers of false
positive detections so any kind of
earth tremor
truck driving by all those kinds of
things produce signals that they end up
detecting these interferometers there's
two things that save them
one is that actually it has the the
things that you're looking for so things
like this black hole signature have a
very characteristic
shape to them that the way that the
oscillations increase and decrease in
amplitude with time has this very
classic signature to it that tells you
the kind of thing you're looking for so
they know what sort of thing to look for
and then the second thing that saved
them is that there isn't just one
interferometer there's two working at
the same time a large distance apart
from one another and so the chances of
the same pathological truck going past
both of them at the same time producing
something that looks exactly like a
black hole merger signature is at that
point astronomically small so they can
by doing this kind of coincidence thing
of detecting it in both detectors almost
simultaneously tells them that actually
they have detected a real astrophysical
result one of the upsides to actually
having two detectors if the
gravitational wave is coming from over
here somewhere it will hit one detector
first and then a bit later it will hit
the other detector so the wave came
through hit louisiana first
and then the la the light travel time
because they're going at the speed of
light
it then passed through
uh the washington detector exactly the
same profile
seven milliseconds later which
corresponds to the light travel time
and that enabled them to sort of give an
estimate of where in the sky
this original thing had started from so
for example this thing that they've
detected they know it's somewhere in the
southern hemisphere they can't say much
more than that it's somewhere in the
southern skies is about as close as they
can get but they do at least get some
directional information when they start
getting third and fourth detectors up
obviously that will give them more
information so they'll actually be able
to triangulate much more exactly where
these sources are potentially an issue
for the the gravitational wave community
it could be that we're on the verge of
being inundated now with
black hole buying neutron star
black hole binaries
sort of all all of a sudden they're
everywhere and we just hadn't had the
sensitivity to detect them and now
no one really knows how many there are
out there because they we all that we
have to work on are theories where you
estimate how many you expect there to be
so that i was reading the you know the
expecting of order 40 a year but hey we
may have got that wrong it may be 4 000
or something in which case you have a
bit of a you're a different issue
you have a like an lhc issue where
you've got so many collisions how are
you going to extract out the interesting
physics here you know where the higgs
coming from here you might just have so
much radiation coming gravitational
waves coming in from all of these binary
systems that we think we understand the
binary systems and we're now interested
in finding the weird and wonderful early
universe features that might be well
that would be a nice problem to have i
think
about black holes is you've got two very
massive objects and they're in orbit if
you've got a pair of them in orbit
around each other so a binary black hole
system because when something's moving
around on a circular orbit it's actually
accelerating see they were unlucky right
they they were in their shutdown mode
when this gravitational wave passed
through it traveled for a billion years
it was there those detectors were up and
running maybe a few months earlier
but they just shut down and it passed
through lincoln
can you miss it